they sound a lot like voices or like an
angry choir somebody told me that they
sound a lot like sniffing a whole lot of
magic markers all at once
you can decide for yourself
i'm andy cavatorta and i'm a sculptor i
work with robotics and the sound
the work that i mostly do
involves creating new types of musical
instruments or new types of physical
sounds a lot of times this has a lot to
do with motion and form
what i'm sitting next to right here it's
called the dervishes it's got these 14
spinning arms
it's similar to the toys that you played
with as a kid where you might spin a
corrugated plastic tube over your head
there's a lot of circuit boards in here
for motor control and we measure the
speeds very precisely
and then there's a lot of software that
takes
the specific pitches
figures out exactly where they should be
played and at what speeds
it's a lot of fine tuning
all the way through from the music that
gets written for it
to the software that calibrates and
adjusts and controls it all the way
through to the fine tuning in the motor
controllers
what i do is a bit on a parallel track
with a lot of what's happening in
electronic music
but i work specifically almost
exclusively with physical sound almost
never with synthesized sound or samples
or stuff like that just because those
are the ones that actually have the most
meaning to me
all my life i've been interested in
sound
i think it's how i figure things out
i always love when these instruments
create
the possibility to make music that
didn't exist before
you